teenagers stood before a judge today
pleading guilty to violently attacking
his teacher thank you for joining us at
four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Sasha
Loftus and for Brian tonight this
incident LED Clark County School leaders
and lawmakers to propose legislation to
enhance school safety eight news now is
the only TV station in the courtroom
today Joshua piguero Joins Us in the
studio with the details Joshua hello uh
Sachin Kirsten Jonathan Martinez Garcia
didn't let his emotions show in court
today but once he set guilty for
attempted murder you heard his family's
reaction
their son is in custody they don't
understand what happened and so they're
dealing with that process as well and
obviously everyone's very worried about
sentencing because it's such a big range
Martinez Garcia pleaded guilty to three
counts after initially facing 15 charges
for axi committed a year ago at the age
of
16.ly farm also category D Felony how do
you plead guilty or not guilty
prosecutors say he tried to sexually
assault and take the life of his teacher
at El Dorado High School he did
willfully unlawfully feloniously and
with MAO support thought attempt to kill
the individual with the initials sa of
human being by strangling Essay with
your hands the teacher suffered these
injuries because of the attack a judge
says Martinez Garcia threw a bookshelf
at the teacher and tried cutting her
wrist with scissors last month the
victim joined Governor Lombardo in Las
Vegas as he announced legislation to
make schools safer shade was not the
first victim of the heinous and horrific
School violence but we are fighting to
make her one of the last the attack let
the teacher hospitalized for a week
Martinez Garcia faces decades Behind
Bars the state will be able to argue for
up to 22 to 55 years in prison we intend
on asking for probation and it's also
it's going to be up to the judge
now Martinez Garcia is sentencing a
schedule for June 5th prosecutors said
in court the teacher who was attacked
wants to attend that sentence in Kirsten